Okay, so I've got it now.
Now that we have
the application packaged up,
it's got to be time to copy
down to the server and run it.
>> Slow down there Cowboy,
while you could do that,
it kind of defeats the point the whole
point of using Docker was to make it
easy to distribute your applications.
What you propose works for
a small set of machines but
won't scale to say a hundred machines.
The right thing to do in this case
is to push your container images
to a remote repository and leverage
tools like Docker to fetch those images
from a central place
when we need to run them.
>> Okay, I think I've heard of those.
Are you talking about Docker Hub?
>> Yes.
>> But if I use that can't
anyone access my containers?
>> Yes, all images you push to
the Docker Hub are public by default.
But don't worry, you also have the
option to make those images private and
limit access to them.
You also have the flexibility to share
some images public and others private.
This often is the case when companies
have open source projects they want to
share with the world but
keep their secret sauce to themselves.
>> Okay, I get it but I think this is
something I need to see in action.